in blue you see that steady line of 145k
hey in red series a happens now you're
up about 175 not bad right not too
shabby and hey you get the series B now
you get that quarter million dollar
salary public Founders midsize companies
are getting a half million a million in
compensation so as a small company like
a series B you're far from being
publicly traded but you're still getting
$250,000 not Chum change it's a very
nice lifestyle There's Hope here that
you can if you hit the milestones your
investors are more than happy to
increase your compensation that's the
basic message here yeah I to totally
agree the more resources you have the
better you are at fundraising you're
going to be able to pay yourself more
and again you're also going to be
scaling the team you're going to have
different kinds of responsibilities
they're going to need you to be more of
an executive and so they're going to pay
you for that